verdon lac est mort jument installée
dans les jardins des ambassadeurs aux
champs elysées balade est en train de
faire mon portrait sur un diable et moi
je tiens à vous remercier car vraiment
vous avez été très gentil de nous
envoyer de si nombreuses lettres pour
nous de veegaete lundi sur les lettres
sont passés au dernier conservatoire de
la chanson je vous rappelle notre
adresse petit conservatoire de la chasse
à mireille 407 ch de grenelle paris 7e
tiens pas la double mireille pendant
qu'elle n'est pas là pour savoir
pourquoi vous aimez me veil
pourquoi vous aimez la femme qui se
cabre ailleurs trois personnes nicole
d'un petit lutin devrait connaître
secret de jeunesse
jocelyne l'adorable fait qu'ils manient
la belgique avec beaucoup d'actrices
daniel ou un 200 m
carpenteyre sans talent de chanteuse
perdre un mois pour tout ce qu'elle a
menées dans le tour de chant dans votre
l'ibère parce qu'elle est très dure avec
elle-même et pas seulement avec
elle-même et avec les gens que la mène
défense d'arsène tranquillité dans la
bouche d'or s'est baladé nu
vous connaissez le côté fermières de
mireille d'installer dans sa maison de
campagne
qu'elle s'occupe de ses moutons et de
ses brebis parce qu'il faut dire que
mireille à des moutons extraordinaires
qui sont des personnages auxquels on
peut parler de charlotte qui a craint
que des tabacs ya juliette
il y à bombay à mardi il ya aussi fermé
jusqu'à lundi
on a toute la semaine enfermé dans le
bureau le trap l'amigo entrave bons
boutons mais la fin de la semaine ça
m'aide
on dit ça n'est pas trop tôt quand on
l'a pris tant de peine de prendre un peu
de repos lorsque l'on mange sonne midi
midi au bureau plus personne personne
jusqu'à lundi et si au téléphone va t'en
dis patron la patronne de tout le monde
est parti michel lis pas le pech du le
fait des amis
et robert se dépêche d'aller retrouver
mimi on a mis sur la porte à vis à vis
au razer de toutes sortes fermé jusqu'à
lundi
tous les jours le chef comptable me fais
sans en avoir l'air un peu de pied sous
la table tout de même sur les mers
lorsqu'il me dit une lettre en pétrole
où plaisante je ne sais plus où me
mettre
mais le samedi matin lorsque alors
larsson midi midi himdi ma petite
mignonne mais dont jusqu'à lundi répond
mon vieux bonhomme
merci merci mais pour voir votre paume
toute la semaine me suffit
non vraiment je regrette mais vous voyez
là bas mon amoureux peut-être ai-je eu
vol dans ses bras une amie sur la porte
à vis à vis aura heures de toutes sortes
ont fermé jusqu'à lundi
oui oui attendent en attendant pour le
menton spectateurs que mireille comme
tout le monde a des ennuis et la détente
est là on lui a dit qu'elle a à cactus
en souvenir de simulateurs et bien mes
enfants nous allons avoir une scierie de
cactus parce que j'ai l'impression que
nous sommes sortis au leader
encore mois à nice pure en animeront
après les variétés une heure de
magazines
nous
non
carnaby street c'est à londres
croyez-vous pas à londres seulement vous
allez voir un reportage de josé weber et
gangs ou rien'
même
bonjour madame bonjour mademoiselle
bonjour monsieur merci d'être fidèle à
notre rendez vous de ce dimanche 19
septembre
désormais si vous le voulez bien chaque
dimanche à cette même heure
nous nous retrouverons pour jouer
ensemble à notre nouveau jeu
le mot le plus long et puisque vous nous
fait l'amitié de nous recevoir chez vous
je vais vous demander de vous installer
le plus confortablement possible pas
trop loin de votre récepteur de
télévision de façon à ce que nous
puissions être très près les uns des
autres et que vous puissiez jouer avec
nous car ne l'oubliez pas ce jeu a été
fait pour que vous amis téléspectateurs
vous puissiez jouer avec nous exactement
dans les mêmes conditions que nos
concurrents en studio rassurez-vous la
règle de notre jeu est extrêmement
simple
je pense qu'il n'est pas utile que je
vous donne au départ de très longues
explications il suffit que vous ne
regardiez joué pendant quelques minutes
et vous aurez tout de suite compris et
vous rentrerez dans le jeu avec nous il
faut pourtant que je vous présente les
différents éléments de ce jeu tout
d'abord nous aurons deux concurrents
deux concurrents qui vont jouer l'un
contre l'autre et qui vont s'affronter
sur ce parcours ce parcours que vous
voyez qui comporte 18 15 9 blanche et 9
noir vous saurez tout à l'heure pour
quoi bien entendu le vainqueur sera
celui qui aura franchi à la fin de la
partie c'est à dire à la fin de
l'émission le plus grand nombre de cases
il y a bien entendu d'autres précisions
que je vous donnerai en cours de jeu
comment l'as vence sur le parcours
va-t-elle s'effectuer bien dans le moule
plus long nous avons remplacé le des
traditionnels des jeux de société
parages
deux lettres chaque concurrent va
disposer de cette lettre à l'aide
desquels il devra composer un mot s'il
fait un mot de trois lettres
il avancera de trois quarts s'il fait un
mot de quatre lettres il avancera de
4,15
mais si un candidat par exemple fait un
mot de quatre lettres mais que son
adversaire fait lui un mot de cinq
lettres
c'est ce dernier qui avancera puisqu'il
aura fait le mot le plus long
il ya d'autres précisions que je vous
donnerai tout à l'heure en cours de
partie pour ne pas vous embrouiller
mais nos candidats nos concurrents les
connaissent déjà
j'ai d'ailleurs vous les présenter ses
concurrents bonjour messieurs c'est très
gentil d'être venu essuyé les plâtres en
quelque sorte de notre émission j'espère
que ça nous portera chance et à vous
aussi monsieur quel est votre nom pierre
mme monsieur armand votre profession
chef de publicité oui et vous habitez
colombes colombes secondes du risque
paris et vous monsieur jean-pierre
lichtenberg étudiants en médecine
j'habite à paris paris donc c'est
presque paris contre pas bon et bien et
je dois encore vous présenter quelques
uns mais là c'est une surprise
eh bien oui vous le reconnaissez c'est
monsieur pichon monsieur pichot qui fut
l'un des héros de l'homme du 20e siècle
et ce soir aujourd'hui monsieur pichon
n'est pas avec nous en qualité de
candidat non armand jammot lui a demandé
de venir m'aider en quelque sorte à
animer cette émission est de remplir le
rôle très important d'arbitré
dictionnaire puisque vous le savez
monsieur pichon et professeurs
professeur d'histoire je crois monsieur
michaud rue
donc personne autre que lui n'était
mieux qualifiés pour trancher les débats
en cas de litige sur un mot et
d'ailleurs il va vous expliquer beaucoup
mieux que moi ce qu'il va faire dans
cette émission monsieur qui changent
rien que vos traces petits enfants sont
à l'école c'est bien entendu la voulez
vous nous expliquer ce que vous allez
faire dans l'émission et bien voilà
comme vous venez de le dire je vais
servir d'arbitré en même temps deux
poseurs de questions je crois que c'est
bien mon tour m'ont assez posé et
messieurs les concurrents écoutez bien
ce que je vais vous dire parce que vous
n'avez pas le droit de composer tous les
maux avec
les athlètes qu'il sort va vous désignez
sont exclues parce que la numération
sous les noms propres de toute nature
les mots d'une fête les formes conjuguer
des verbes sauf toutefois l'infinitif et
le participe passé les onomatopées et
des interdictions les préfixes et les
suffixes les fines comme connu ce
terrain les abréviations le tc et c'est
lé symbole chimique par an pour le
cuivre cu et je crois que quand j'aurai
terminé cette énumération je n'aurai
plus qu'un mot à ajouter pour vous
encourager c'est que je serai
impitoyable pour les fautes
d'orthographe c'est très bien vous avez
compris monsieur bon eh bien je vous
rappelle que j'ai devant moi deux sabots
contenant d'un côté des voyelles et de
l'autre des consonnes que vous allez
pouvoir me demander dans l'ordre ils
vous convient
je vous rappelle messieurs et je le dis
surtout à l'adresse de nos amis
téléspectateurs vous avez 45 secondes
pour demander vos lettres et pour
composer votre mot alors je vais tirer
au sort avec cette pièce pour savoir
celui d'entre vous qui aura l'avantagé
toutefois son état de commencer
pile ou face est-ce que vous choisissez
race faste ses piles c'est pile alors
monsieur lichtenberg c'est à vous de
commencer la petite lumière est allumée
devant vous je demande le chronomètre
top c'est parti
pierre lazareff pierre d'eyraud pierre
dumayet et igor barrère vous propose
cinq colonnes à la une
mais
et bien ici compiègne ville d'art et
d'histoire et finaliste d'intervilles
1964 nous sommes place de l'hôtel de
ville
bonjour à tous bonjour monsieur richard
et surtout bon dimanche souhaiter bon
dimanche à tous le monde mais c'est
tellement devant je me suis mis sur un
tabouret et vous vous êtes à votre
bureau directorial bon dimanche ou pour
chacun rien ne doit être impossible ni
vivres ni sourire ni se détend ni
s'amuser ni mieux se connaître ni se
rendent service veut bien d'accord afin
que cette campagne cette opération au
rpf deviennent en quelque sorte le
dénominateur commun de tous les
auditeurs de tous les téléspectateurs
impossible n'est pas français et
d'ailleurs ça a bien débuté puisque déjà
il ya plusieurs épreuves de réussie nous
avons eu hier soir en effet en compagnie
de pierre sabbagh est quand même
peut-être temps de le rappeler pour tous
ceux de nos amis qui n'était pas aller
coûte les 35 heures ni la télé hier soir
nous allons présenter le sympathique
compiégnois monsieur raymond richard et
je voudrais rappeler ou plutôt qui va le
faire lui-même sa fiche signalétique
alors n'est né le 2 septembre 1924 j'ai
pas faisable de l'irak ont fait
profession aux pressions pdg qualité
possède est léger mais un pdg
sympathique je crois que vous êtes aussi
ouvriers vous mettez la main là pas de
depuis ce matin d'ailleurs il a fallu
lui mettre la main à la pâte recettes
livret de caisse d'épargné de prévoyance
aujourd'hui notre passion la télévision
les voyages et voyages bon
votre préféré * d'amis dans son planning
particulier depuis l'interview dans les
interviews d'ailleurs ça me permet de
dire que si nous avons choisi monsieur
richard c'est en effet dans ce qu'il y a
trois ans il a permis à compiègne
d'arriver en finale d'intervilles
et c'est à lui que nous devons d'avoir
eu des locomotives pour la présenter
hier soir avoir eu des monstres
mécaniques et nord mais aussi d'avoir eu
quelques 2000 personnes qui s'était
laissé pousser la barbe et quelques 3
400 qui s'était rasé dont vous mais ça
n'a pas repoussé et aujourd'hui pourtant
vous vous faites des choix et nous avons
tous bords alors j'ajoute maintenant que
tout ce alors ça c'est à l'intention de
tous les téléspectateurs de tous les
auditeurs que tous ceux qui jouent avec
nous monsieur richard risque de partager
une partie de vos gains ce qui joue sur
france inter depuis 9h ce matin et
qu'ils vont jouer à partir de maintenant
sur la première chaîne télévision et
tout ceci jusqu'à 19h30 ce soir
autonomie de 9 heures à 19 heures 30
sauteurs que ce soir un marathon de
10h30 d'antenne il est commencé il se
poursuit et j'espère que tout le monde
va jouer avec compiègne c'est déjà
commencé puisqu'il ya des résultats et
mais maintenant quel est votre secret
pour être décontracté lot il y en a pas
d qu'on est avec vous on peut pas être
autrement
rabat et pékin croyez vous en bras de
chemise et la première les premiers cap
bon en tous les cas sur france inter à
9h ce matin le grand départ a été donné
vous avez attaqué courageusement votre
marathon de 10h30 auquel je faisais
allusion il y à quelques instants or à 8
heures ça avait commencé pour ou
lorsqu'on vrai soulisse 50 épreuves vous
en avez éliminé 30 comme réduite est
totalement impossible
oui je ne sais pas d'ailleurs si les
vagues que j'ai choisi pour permettre de
réussir à prouver que c'est impossible
alors que vous désirez charente
connaître les premiers résultats des
épreuves qui ont été lancés sur france
inter par nos amis il serait quand même
bon quand même de parler un peu de vos
gains et si vous permettez je vais
passer d'or qui va nous permettre
d'ailleurs de voir deux tableaux
représentant des deux tableaux le
premier celui ci vaio qui indiquent
toutes les épreuves de manière
préliminaire toute épreuve ce que
monsieur richard va devoir accomplir
aujourd'hui la statue le déménagement le
tir à la corde n'utilise pas qu'en face
tout ça c'est un petit peu
arrivé pour vous mais vous allez voir ça
va s'éclairer au fur et à mesure de
l'émission et à chaque fois qu'il
n'éprouvait russie on passe sur ce
tableau le plus intéressant et d'un seul
coup on s'aperçoit que l'opération
trèfle a été réussi l'opération soyez
polyglotte on va en parler dans quelques
secondes
et cela a rapporté 2 x 500 francs à
monsieur richard car en effet voici la
progression des gains quel que soit
l'ordre dans lequel monsieur richard
réalisé des preuves
les cinq premières leur apporte 500
francs les cinq suivantes mille francs
les cinq suivantes 2000 francs puis la
16e et la 17e 3000 la 18e 4000 la 19e
5000 et alors nous sommes très ambitieux
la 20e qui sera réalisé dix sept mille
cinq cents francs c'est à dire qu'à la
fin s'il a réalisé le grand chelem sur
icha recevra 50 mille francs 5 millions
d'enfants qui sera partagée et dont
d'ailleurs maintenant il va nous donner
l'utilisation si vous gagnez s'il vous
reste quelque chose de si riche à assise
le reste quelque chose ce soir j'ai
pensé que la ville de compiègne n'ayant
pas d'autobus
on pourrait acheter l'autobus d'ailleurs
ça c'est amusant parce que furent à
mesure que nous allons essayer de
réaliser ces épreuves nous paraissait
impossible au fur et à mesure que des
gars vont s'accumuler
eh bien on va construire cet opus
ensemble on va d'abord faire rouler la
dali et roule ni toit depuis ce matin
car vous savez qu'il ya une fois du
règlement qui démentent souligné on n'a
peut-être pas dit sur france inter vous
avez le droit d'engager pour essayer de
négocier des transactions pour payer des
aides bénévoles vous allez devoir gagner
la moitié de vos gains ce que vous avez
déjà acheté ces collaborations pas
encore tout à fait gratuit vous voyez je
prends connaissance vidal gagnant les
gens sont bel événement avec vous bon
alors maintenant entrons dans le vif du
sujet à 9 heures ce matin
enfin ne le retient d'exactement france
inter lancer la première épreuve enfin
celle que vous aviez considérée comme la
première à lancer parce que vous avez
fait votre petit lexique classification
d'urgence il s'agissait d'une course
camping paris et nous allons en voir les
images regardez